今天要來當沖
6770的力積電
速度10倍
今天手機不在我手上
特別注意
今天所有教學內容
不是推薦個股
沒有進出場建議
任何投資都有風險
一定要評估自己
是否有辦法承擔
準備好
我們當沖開始
你會讓我賺到錢的吧？
加油
好緊張喔
第一次是我自己
你想要做多還是做空？
還不知道
我等一下學你
看60K
想要做多你就找支撐
想要放空就找壓力
60K
現在在支撐區
對吧？
你哪裡有支撐區？
我怎麼沒看到？
好我再看一次
你的支撐在哪裡？
這裡啊？
這個這個
沒有啊
那不算啊
對啊那不算
你應該是看到
上面有壓力
這根壓力有沒有？
大根的黑K壓力
這根
最高點多少？
好 70.4
你就把它當作一個
分水嶺
來了來了
沒有
你要先看70.4
有沒有過啊
你看70.4有沒有？
他剛才就卡在那邊
點一次
你剛才其實已經有
出手一次機會
然後下來你已經賺錢了
有嗎？
現在才上去吧？
沒有
剛才有上去一次
下來吧
不然怎麼會有70.4？
我不知道
他聽到我們講
沒有 就一定是有衝上去
有人用
有人用紅包獲利法
已經賺錢了
我錯過了
老師你害我錯過
這個最佳時機了
所以你在開盤前
你就要先找好壓力點
你看有人看到70.4
搞不好空70.3
你看70.3如果跌到
現在69.8 69.9
你已經賺五角了
如果壓力沒有過的話
你就可以評估說
這邊到70.4
你要不要承擔
這個風險？
我看一下
我覺得不會過
市價！
你空個一張吼 好
對
哎呦
OK
風險就70.4
你成交69.6嘛？
你就要決定說
那個70.4
到底會不會再過？
壓力沒有過的話
你看往下他沒有支撐嘛
對啊
往下沒有支撐
你就不要想太多
你就可以用最簡單的
5分K
比如說最近的
壓力被克服了
或是均價線被突破了
因為它現在應該是一個
趨勢線嘛
5分K在這？
對
開盤多少？
開盤就是69
突破我就可以加空
跌破你可以加空
因為已經拉開了嘛
哎喲哎喲！
哇
快點快點快點
來不及了啦
你看
這時候我已經
成交10張
你還在
你還在那邊按
這個就是速度的不一樣
好
我現在兩張了
對
很猛的很猛的
往下你再看
下一道支撐
目前應該是
沒有支撐嘛
因為他是往下掉啊
對
那我可以再看這裡嗎？
可以啊
前低也可以啊
這個前低
那這裡好了
娃他怎麼反彈了？
68.5
可以啊
最好是能趕快
就去找好支撐壓力
去判斷他
啊看你要用
我們教的
均價線的方向
還是你要用
壓力支撐都可以
但是很多人就是學了
然後當下
欸 慌了！
就不知道怎麼辦
還是我
直接看68.1
我直接掛68.3
也可以啊
你要想說你
剛才空的點到那邊
你可以賺多少
可以先想好
有
那個賺賠比算漂亮
那我給他
空一個68.3
買進吧？
買進
快點喔
要到了要到了
快點喔現在
時間一點一點走
再一張
成交了
成交嘍？
成交了啊
68.1如果沒有破
你就可以繼續停利
如果破的話就繼續加空
我已經...
好 下課了
謝謝
這太速了吧
就是這樣子啊
所以你一天
其實有很多次的交易
但是很多人
就是會有一個迷失
你賺了第一筆就
想要賺第二筆
但是有時候其實來
我先問你
一天薪水多少？
不要假的啦
你做工的人喔
不要假
沒有啊
我們正職應該
假日也要算吧
沒有啦
我們算日薪嘛
一個月薪水除以
22個工作天
你要算除以30喔？
對啊
你還把假日算進去
應該是除以30吧
我們問問看（觀眾）
除以30
OK
一天薪水1500嘛
所以我建議同學
以日薪的一半
加薪一半算很好了吧
是不是？ 來
看一下我們今天
已實現獲利目前多少
老師等一下
我們要不要先
講一下這個走勢
沒有啊
就看你要繼續做
還是不要繼續做啊
那我抓點抓得漂亮吧
他真的68.1守住
因為一定會去測嘛
這邊做多的人
他就會想說
好 如果你不破
他就會跑進去買
啊如果這邊破
有人就會跑進去放空啊
對啊
短線的交易邏輯是這樣
如果你用60K就
看比較長的
波段的人
他會看哪邊的支撐壓力
你就要去想好
那我今天這個
其實蠻簡單的
我就單純只是用
其實很簡單
其實現在的股價波動
其實你要做
而且手續費
你只要夠便宜
三折以下
基本上就是
抖一下
你看你已經賺錢了
哎呦
他破底了
對啊
就看你要不要繼續做
就這樣子而已啊
不做了
我見好就收
你看
如果第一筆
你早上空在壓力點
就算他被突破了
你頂多賠幾百塊嘛
但是如果對了的話
你看從70.4
到現在67.4
哇！多少？
3000塊
嗯
一張3000
兩張6000
三張9000
四張12000
5張多少？
九九乘法學不好
做股票一定要
學好九九乘法表
老師我發現一件事
就是
我們其實真的
當下在做當沖的時候
好像沒有真的用太多
那個什麼
不用啊
形態啊...
當沖看的是當下
所以當沖又有
兩種門派
一種叫Tick流
Tick流看比較短
就是我固定要賺個
三檔五檔
他就要獲利
一筆大概賺個
比如說500塊
到1000塊
然後一天十筆就
5000塊到10000塊了
那很嚇人喔
所以其實
算起來真的蠻可觀的
但是很多人
就是會迷失在這邊
然後想說
一天賺5000塊
一個月就賺多少？
我們先反問自己
一個月薪水多少？
你一天上班8小時
你就賺2000塊
難道
你已經賺了
1000塊2000塊
你還不滿足嗎？
先見好就收
累積一筆錢之後
你後面就越有底氣了
絕對不要想要
一夕致富
想說
一天如果賺一萬
我就要FIRE老闆
絕對不要有這種想法
慢慢來
所以其實
外面學很多
那些當沖方法
有點太複雜了
我看你用的
基本上就是
60K 5K就解決了
對啊
簡單方法最有用啊
為什麼？
我過去用過很多種
當沖方法
我把最好的那幾招
整理起來
叫做當沖七大獲利術
每一招我都有研究出
最好的買賣方式
真的可以做到
勝率又高
賺的又多
賠的又少
這七大獲利術
我都有放在我們
線上直播講座裡
點連結就可以免費報名
之前有很多學員
學完這七招
獲利突飛猛進
講座名額有限
如果點進去
沒有看到場次
代表額滿了
趕快把握機會
點連結報名
老師那我今天也算是
示範一個那種
上班族
在上班之前
我半小時內
就當沖完了
沒有半小時
你在嗯嗯的時間
就沖完了
OKOK
那我們來看一下
我賺多少
剛剛好
今天拿到我的日薪